et cet étudiant en médecine a succombé à
une thrombose le 18 mars après s'être
fait injecter le vaccin strazeele et
carl étienne boitant représente sa
famille l'avocat a déposé une plainte
pénale pour défendre les intérêts
d'autres personnes décédées dans des
circonstances similaires
il demande que toute la lumière soit
faite sur les causes des décès et le
lien éventuel avec l'injection de ces
romains du sérum anglo-suédois notre
interrogation aujourd'hui c'est de
savoir si c'est le vaccin en tant que
tel si c'est la façon dont le vaccin a
été injecté mais il apparaît aujourd'hui
relativement probable que ce soit bien
qu'il existe bien un lien entre eux la
gestion d'astrazeneca et la survenance
de la thrombose ce que les flammes l'ibl
c'est à voir les conclusions du rapport
d'autopsié et ensuite de comprendre ce
qui s'est passé et éventuellement après
rechercher des responsabilités j'ai
également été contacté par d'autres
personnes qui portent heureusement ne
sont pas décédés mais certaines me dit
avoir eu lui propose après l'injection
j'étudie chaque cas je fais tu n'y
échappe pas avec des médecins
spécialisés pour faire la part des
choses entre ce qui peut relever du
vaccin est ce qui peut relever
évidemment d'autres choses